je veux entretenir sur la finance qui
sur les mécanismes qui existent
et notamment fait un focus sur des
crédits carbone vous entendez parler du
crédit carbone donc on va un peu en
parler alors avant de commencer je vais
vous dire d'abord que les changements
climatiques c'est un comportement 3 1 1
1 1 point qui l'ont marqué il faut
partir avec et je vais vous donner aussi
une check-list que j'essaie j'essaie
d'avoir souvent à la maison ici c'est un
peu compliqué mais quand je suis en
mission dans les hôtels j'essaie quand
même de deux
d'avoir ce comportement là et tous les
matins en sortant de ma chambre d'hôtel
je veille à ce que la lumière soit
détente et je veille à ce que le robinet
d'eau ne coule pas où et je fais
attention en disant aux mines à 0 22
million de chambres de ne pas changer le
monde à ne pas changer ses des
comportements qu'il faut essayer d'avoir
pour contribuer d'une certaine façon à
la réduction des émissions des gaz à
effet de serre alors campagne de la
science qui m'a comme la finance
classique
tout le monde a un peu de difficulté à
voir ou est-ce qu'il faut mobiliser des
ressources mais avant de commencer je
veux qu'on s'accorde sur la définition
que je donne à la finance qui m'a la
définition initiale qui avait été
retenu par les nations unies dit que
c'est tout financement qui concourent à
l'adaptation et à l'atténuation
bon c'est un peu compliqué mais allons
en français facile c'est tout
financement qui concourent à la
réduction des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre et qui qui réduit aussi les
effets néfastes contre les écosystèmes
ils savent qu'on à l'atténuation et
l'adaptation
alors aujourd'hui nous avons
énormément de ressources qui existent il
ya énormément d'argent qui existent
quand vous parlez de finances climat et
tous mieux voir à cette porte est là
depuis 2015 avec
l'accord de paris
la définition de la finale qui m'a a
énormément évolué on est passé de
finances impôts l'atténuation
l'adaptation à une finance qui prend en
compte les objectifs de développement
durable et depuis 2000 2002 2018 on a
encore évolué en y intégrant des
questions liées à la biodiversité des
questions liées à
l'inclusion de l'être humain dans tout
financement que vous faites donc comme
toi vous pensez finances qui m'a pop on
sait à
quel est le rôle quel est l'impact que
vous avez sur l'être humain alors les
pays lors de la cop de paris ont soumis
ce que nous appelons les contributions
déterminées au niveau national ce sont
des programmes qui prennent en compte je
prends l'exemple du togo page du togo
qui prennent en compte le pnd qui
prennent en compte les stratégies
nationales qui prenne en compte toutes
les politiques et liées au changement
climatique mais dans
ccl d'ici pour nous appelons les
contributions tenait un débat national
qui les pays ont pris des engagements et
ses engagements la sauce prix et les
chiffres si je vous le dis ah non pas un
énorme et pour arriver à mobiliser chip
là il faut avoir tout le monde autour de
la table je veux parler spécifiquement
du secteur privé à ce que je pense
personnellement les je crois que l'avis
est partagé e
pouvoir mobiliser ces ressources là il
faut forcément impliquer le secteur
privé
la problématique que nous avons en
allant vers le secteur privé on s'est
rendu compte que beaucoup de personnes
dans le secteur privé écrivent des
projets mais malheureusement ils
l'écrivent pas en y intégrant les
critères de lisibilité des institutions
financières vers laquelle ils vont je
prends un exemple
je développe imposé j'ai cru le projet
il est bien beau il est bien structuré
il est bien lisible et très très bien
structuré en français mais
malheureusement je vais voir d'un et
comment où les lois d et quand j'arrive
je la dépose mon dossier sans ce moment
que peuvent ils reviennent vers moi en
me disant à marcher moubarak nous a fait
amenez votre dossier il est bien écrit
mais
c'est dans les limites d'intervention ne
leur permettent pas d'aller le voir
plonger et c'est en ce moment que nous
ne peut prendre que vous qu'on s'est pas
amélioré nettement dossier alors
initialement ce que la promotion du
secteur privé c'est quoi ces de redire
avant de faire un projet mettez sur la
table toutes les institutions
financières qui sont dans votre milieu
établissez les critères d'éligibilité
ces institutions financières là et après
vous voyez lesquels sont plus proches de
votre projet lesquels auprès desquels
vous pouvez vous adresser et avec ce
c'était aussi cela nous allons commencer
par voie que à au film au fur et à
mesure les agents du secteur privé les
gens du secteur privé commence à prendre
conscience de cette méthodologie cette
approche ou développer les projets et
nous avons donc nous sommes donc dit bon
voilà un panier qui atteint et
maintenant nous faisons un travail nous
avons fait un travail de renforcement et
aussi aux intrusions financière en leur
montrant leur apprenons les la passion
d'analyser la façon de regarder les
projets liés au changement climatique
parce que dans un premier temps que vous
prenez un projet ni au changement
climatique s'est imposée à la base dont
le retour sur investissement n'est pas
élevé dans leurs sources de retour de
cette privés accordent très rapidement
le secteur privé n'est pas enclin à
aller vers ces ressources là surtout
s'ils se passaient france qui doit aller
vers une scission financiers qui ont des
taux d'intérêt assez assez élevé alors
nous avons parlé avec les options
financières ou mettre en place des
mécanismes financiers pour attirer ou
permettre de financer ccc c'est pourtant
de congés là mais l'autre chose qui est
primordial qui est très importante c'est
là le pouvoir public l'implication du
coup voie publique et c'est là que nous
pensons qu'il faut faire un travail
majeur dans nos pays et le pouvoir
public nous pensons doit mettre en place
une certaine politique des politiques
des règles pour inciter le secteur privé
à venir dans le cadre de ces types de
projets là parce que nous pensons que le
secteur privé aujourd'hui non seulement
il ya de la limite est de 7 à brison de
la ruhr est de 2,2 cette pub est un
vecteur de création d'emplois il crée
beaucoup plus facilement de l'emploi que
que les états et autres dans goon
encourageant des états a vraiment aller
dans ce sens là alors d'un point de vue
global la question liée à la garantie
des projets est primordiale elle est
très importante donc aujourd'hui nous
travaillons avec des pour mettre en
place des mécanismes de garanties pour
que ce secteur privé là au moment
d'investir dans son projet n'est pas de
problème n'est pas de souci à se faire
quant à si jamais le projet ne se passe
pas bien à cause d un certain nombre de
risques notamment je me dis un risque
politique par exemple qui soit bac et
qui est une garantie
qui n'est pas forcément une garantie
d'état qui puisse le couvrit je suis
service là donc c'est les outils sur
lesquels on travaille alors dans le
cadre de la mobilisation des
financements pour la mise en oeuvre des
décisions des cons truction détermine au
niveau national de l'accord de paris
nous avons une panoplie d'instruments
que nous sommes en train de mettre en
place et notamment nous se rendront de
mettre en place ce que nous appelons la
tarification carbone et 7 la région
carbone elle est simple et c'est juste à
encourager les gens qui font des efforts
pour réduire les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre et même au niveau des
gouvernements je prends l'exemple du
besoin de tours par exemple qui a faim
un lac magnifique mais que personne n'a
ne regarde comme un acte de réduction
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
c'est la loi des finances de 2018 ce qui
réduit de la taxation sur un nouveau
véhicule et quand vous avez deux mille
2018 voudrait que le pacte automobile de
nommer a changé il ya beaucoup de belles
voitures dans la ville de lomé
aujourd'hui mais c'est 70 là permet à
l'état de dire nous avons un parc
automobile nous avons fait une analyse
sur ce parc automobile là aujourd'hui
avec le changement de ce pacte nous
avons quand même une réduction des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et ça
contribue à la mise en oeuvre mais
d'essayer ces deux petites actions comme
ça que nous regardons et nous
encourageons de plus en plus les états à
dire si vous avez pris des engagements
de réduction des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre
vous pouvez plus subventionner les
produits pétroliers au même niveau que
voulez subventionner avant nous ne vous
demandons pas de mettre une taxe
additionnelle mais pour encourager les
gens à faire des panneaux solaires ont
croisé des gens qui travaillent dans le
secteur de réduction des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre par exemple
réduisez la subvention sur les produits
pétroliers par exemple et vous les
mettez les notions les panneaux solaires
et vous verrez le bel avantage que ça de
d'impulser une certaine dynamique dans
ce sens à l'autre sur laquelle nous
travaillons avec et c'est dans ce cadre
à deux avec toute la sous région c'est
sur un mécanisme de marché parce que
pour que tout ça ait du sens pour par
exemple vous avez des étiquettes de
réduction d'émissions de gaz à effet de
serre pour pouvoir les monétiser pour
pouvoir les vendre sur le marché il faut
avoir un cadre réglementé
institutionnels donc est ce cadre
réglementé institutionnel est régie par
l'article 6 de l'accord de paris qui est
l'article sur les mécanismes ans et le
financement et cet article là c'est le
plus gros débat aujourd'hui que nous que
nous avons parce que il ya une partie
des personnes qui veulent que
cet article 6 la prennent en compte les
appuis budgétaires qu'on fait à nos pays
tout ce qui est en accord bilatéral
entre nos pays et nos pays disney
malheureusement non c'est vrai nous
avons besoin d'argent mais nous n'avons
pas de prendre à n'importe quel prix et
pour aller au delà nous mettons en place
dès les pays ont décidé de la vidéo par
exemple
mettre en place un marché où entre les
états entre les sociétés privées de la
zone on puisse échanger librement les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
c'est cette alliance qui a été créée et
ça s'appelle de ouest africaine
et c'est à lyon cela permet aujourd'hui
de structurer le marché et nous avons
déjà vu des échanges des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre sur ce marché là
alors je juste avant deux avant de venir
ici je regardais de prix de la tonne du
quart du co2 du carbone est sûrement
c'est réglementaire il est très fin et
environ 0 4 centime la peine et quand
vous voyez ça vous êtes un peu de
croiser mais il ne changera des 3es
nationale les 4 centimes la fusion des
ressources additionnelles à votre projet
donc c'est dans ce sens là qu'il peut y
penser et aujourd'hui je regardais aussi
au niveau 2 en france la tonne de co2
dans le cadre réglementaire et échanger
à 33 euros la tonne et c'est là que ça
fait là ça fait toute la différence et
les entreprises en france aujourd'hui
qui n'ont pas les moyens de réduire les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre donc
qu'ils sont obligés de venir mettre en
oeuvre des projets dans nos pays ou de
venir acheter des crédits carbone chez
nous pour pouvoir réduire leurs
émissions de gaz à effet de serre qu'ils
émettent
en france et c'est là que ça fait la
différence parce que aujourd'hui nous
avons beaucoup de partenaires qui
viennent vers nous avec des demandes
pour dire écoutez trouver un ou des
crédits carbone dans le domaine de
méthanisation trouvons-nous de cliquer à
beaune tailly domaine des coupes sombres
des foyers améliorés trouver new delhi
il ya énormément de ces mécanismes qui
existent et c'est en sus ses pairs ça
que nous voulons créer marché